hey everybody welcome to stream coco
how's everybody doing on this fine
monday i guess it's afternoon it's 1203.
uh we are incredibly excited uh this
week we have richard garriott
who is i was just saying before we
started the closest person to a
real-life tony stark that i think exists
uh uh he's an entrepreneur you know he
created the ultima series uh uh he's
been to space he's been in the
international space station uh he's been
antarctica he's been to the titanic he's
literally done every single possible
thing you can and i'm pretty i'm going
to try to stab him later he might be
immortal he might be a highlander i
don't know
we don't know
there could be only one spin my games
people spend a lot of time trying to
kill me that's true i work very hard to
become immortal people try to take down
lord british exactly uh and today we're
gonna play a little bit of gauntlet uh
which is uh we were just uh reminiscing
about uh you used to own yeah well i not
only spent you know in the very
beginnings of my career you know i spent
hundreds and hundreds and probably
thousands and thousands of dollars
playing the coin op yes owned a coin off
yes eventually retired all my conauts
because they were you know the i had to
store them in a barn and they just got
dust in them and that was yeah acres of
coin-ops just coin
collecting dust but uh so but i'm a huge
gauntlet fan i haven't played this
version in a while so we're going to see
how it's great very easy and fun i i
will say i like that i'm a valkyrie fan
because she's a badass oh i'm going to
play the off you know i like
my favorite line was elf needs food
exactly i got that uh a lot as well all
right here we go uh how's everybody
doing conan it's my hero good to see you
aaron burton what's up
that's right exactly um yes richard
garrett that's right chainsaw gothic uh
we have also so let's just
briefly talk about your your humble
beginnings
huh so you i i read a thing where you
play it you actually programmed in high
school something like 28
games uh that's true yeah in fact
you know back when when games were way
more primitive than this yeah back in
the old eight well even before 8-bit
even before the apple 2 i was
programming on a teletype that had
nothing but you know character graphics
on paper that's insane and uh
and with those character graphics on
paper you know i would uh you know
create these little role-playing games
and then when the apple ii finally came
out i'd start building little 3d
environments
with the black and white line drawing no
polygons no code textures
nothing like this but uh but even in
those earliest days yeah the the number
of people making them was me and six or
eight other people it seems like that is
unbelievable and so it was pretty easy
going at the very beginning yes there
was more demand than there were makers
and what kind of attracted you in the
very beginning to
to doing it i mean no one no one was
doing this what what made you think i
want to i want to create a game i want
to do oh yeah no it was it was really uh
you know there weren't other computer
games really around the time that much
many there were some text games like the
original adventure game or swords
oh my god i played so much and um uh but
then i was playing dungeons and dragons
when it first came out you know i mean
literally first came out you know
friends of uh gary gygax and dave
arneson when you know after they made
that
and uh
but uh that led us uh
uh you know uh i just kind of made the
thing that you felt natural based upon
you know the love of lord of the rings
yeah yeah it kind of was a natural
extension it was kind of like i guess
one of those things where you know if
you love a book then you want to write
that kind of exactly right kind of
exactly right that's unbelievable and so
i was just combining all the things i
was enjoying the the early computers
the uh early
uh
you know games like uh dnd yeah yeah
fixing like rings so that was just it
all coalesced into computer games and
then and then when ultima started to
take off and you found yourself uh on
the other side of the mirror like
inspiring other people to make video
games and to get into that yeah that had
to be pretty surreal it is but what's
interesting about that is you know for a
long time you don't really know that
that's happening i mean even while it's
happening this is this goes way way
before internet yes yes yes that's true
and i wasn't my own first publisher so
if so if anybody even made a comment to
the publisher it didn't go to me right
for five or ten years but you had no
idea i had no idea you know i just know
it sold well because i get a royalty
check right you know you don't you don't
really understand what people think
about it that's true uh until i had
already been doing it for about a decade
right and after that you started you
begin to get fan mail and what's
interesting about fan mail to this day i
don't know you might tell me if this
matches what you guys get yes i mean
we're getting instantaneous fan mail i
know exactly it's it's much quicker now
it's much easier now for both the trolls
and the fans that's true but uh but back
in my day you know the the letters that
i have that i like that i kept uh all
say things like you know one paragraph
of hey i think your games are really
great and then it's pages here's what
you did wrong well let me tell you how
you could what you should have done
sorry to actually make this
and also how much fun people have
killing your character right well that's
yeah that's the other thing people want
to take down the you know they go to the
top of the pyramid
exactly they wanted they always run for
the throne now what are you do you still
uh do you have time to you're doing so
much other things do you still have time
to play other video games oh yeah i'm
still uh in fact i would say i'm more of
a gamer of the last five years than i
was the previous wow
is there anything that you're liking
these days that you that you think
people should check what's interesting
is i i tend to make big complex
role-playing games yes but i tend to
play
lighter mobile kind of interesting tower
defense games yeah
um like like a few years ago plants vs
you
and
zombies was my like number one game boy
wow
awesome i believe that though because
it's kind of like as a rock musician you
don't really want to listen to the music
you're making you want to listen to
other you're influenced by other stuff
yeah that's exactly right in fact i
think i find my best inspiration from
people who are doing things that aren't
role-playing games sure absolutely also
for people who don't know he coined the
term mmorg by the way that's right
that's unbelievable
which is obviously pretty common yeah i
would say so yeah find that term as well
that's right have you read now have you
read the book uh ready player one of
course oh yeah of course um yeah in fact
i got a uh uh i was just getting ready
for my space flight when ernest cline
wrote that book that's an amazing
sentence by the way yeah he's just
getting ready for me he actually sent a
message to me to write an intro for it
but i was too busy to wow with my other
activities at that preparing fierce
baseball yeah so let's talk about that
so you uh uh the only the second person
ever i believe to wear the british flag
in space that's true uh your father
astronaut that's fruit uh by the way
great mustache i i saw a picture on
wikipedia
yes if you look up owen uh garrett on uh
wikipedia amazing uh amazing mustache
very envious um and uh oh do i have to
revive you here what can i do i don't
know i'm trying to mut back can i how do
i can i bring you back i don't know but
i came back a minute ago but i've now
died twice so there's a little there's a
little over scanning going on on the tv
um wait how do i do my good background
oh there you go
um
yeah so so tell us about that so you so
i have so many questions first of all
obviously okay you decide you're gonna
go into space well i decided that at a
young age so so what's important about
to know about that is uh you know it it
would be reasonable to assume that
because my dad was an astronaut that
that's why i decided i want to be now
sure i would think that yeah but i but i
don't really think that's quite true or
at least it's no more true for me than
it probably was for most kids who grew
up thinking i want to be a you know
dinosaur hunter or
a policeman or fireman but when you grow
up with a sasquatch hunter perhaps
these days
and
but
but so uh
but what happened for me
is uh when i was about 13 years old one
of the nasa doctors who was giving me an
eye test and noticed that i was going to
have to have glasses and he said you
know i hate to break it to you richard
but you are no longer eligible to be an
astronaut whoa is that true and so i
can't be an astronaut well now you can
wow now we're talking about you're
giving me hope i'm jimin can you
continue to have hope because uh
but at that time it was like being
kicked out of the club that you know
your parents and all your neighbors
members of so i was like distraught
uh and i said well like you know who is
the doctor to be the gatekeeper of space
if i can't go by nasa rules i make my
own yes it's like the movie gattaca
you're not going to be like yeah you're
not going to be the limits when i watch
gadoka i'm going like that's me yes
that's you that's me that would have
done all i would have done all the same
thing
i love it so then so then the challenge
it was like it's it's you know if you
ever want me to do something tell me i
can't do it it was one of those right
exactly right that's exactly that's
exactly what happened right and uh and
you know at the age of 13 you don't
really do much
right your hands are a little bit as
soon as i started making money in video
games then i began to do something about
it yes and uh
and so almost all the investing i did by
myself meaning not with a financial
planner yes anything i did myself i
began to invest in opening
space so a week ago right
and you i believe you're a trustee of
the x prize that's one of the one of the
original that's right you know
participants co-founder of zero g which
i almost did which is unbelievable you
need to go do it oh my god i highly
recommend it absolutely uh let's see if
i can get myself brought back and zero g
just for people to know it's it's the
it's the plane that goes on a parabolic
uh arc so then you're you experience
weightlessness
yeah like
is the same as being in space that's
cool i mean it really is because that's
good even the space station is falling
towards the earth it's just missing
right exactly because it's going 17 000
miles an hour
but the sensation you get is identical
that's insane i love it and you actually
and um again one of your many
accomplishments you i think performed
the first wedding you officiated the
first wedding series
that's unbelievable so yeah so i'm an
ordained minister my credentials in my
pocket how did how did
how did that go i mean how did it
actually go with people floating around
did they hold hands like it's tricky
because logistics well you know when
you're when you're floating you we had
fun by purposely like doing parts about
the ceiling sure sure yes but you also
have to break it up into 30 second
parabolas right so we'd like uh you know
do you take this lovely one my wife
and then you're slammed on the floor for
two g's and then do you take this man
we're going to try a different map here
let's try a little something where we
can hack and slash
um that is i'm going to also switch my
guy here uh who should i be i'm going uh
let's go warrior classic look at that
look at he can't use that he can't tie
his shoes he can't get past his belt his
giant skull
he's got like
really uh that is unbelievable that's so
fun oh my god well okay so then okay you
you get some success you get a little
bit of money and then you decide i'm
gonna go into space yeah and of course
getting space is not easy right who do
you what's the first phone call
well actually the first
attempts to get into space were
helping
the nasa folks who were retiring from
nasa who were frustrated they couldn't
convince the government to do it their
way
and who then came to me and said hey
how'd you like to sponsor my you know
crazy scheme to get out of space
interesting and i was going like yeah
well i have a shared vision so let's
let's do it that's cool that's the
problem is those people have had no
prayer of doing it right because they
were all you know test pilots or
uh
super scientists but they weren't
entrepreneurs right they didn't have the
other skills they didn't have the other
skills yeah so the first 10 years of
attempts were were pretty much ten years
buying us and lost a lot of money
backing a lot of
crazy ideas but then i found the folks
like peter dimanus who's the key founder
of the x prize
guy named eric anderson who helped me
kick off zero g and space adventures
uh and a whole list of others uh and
that's really how it began to open up
wow this sequence of more
entrepreneurial activities that's so
cool and then so and and so you guys
kind of get together and
and how do you because it seems to me
it's it crosses so many different i mean
you need to have money you need to have
resources you've got to get you have to
get permission from governments right
you can't just shoot something up with
governments yes that's a great you know
for a small you know broke team of five
yes yeah it's pretty hard to negotiate
with governments
uh but we did
and it still took another 10 years
almost but it but even but it did
eventually work right uh and uh but then
but then it gets worse after that
because just because you built a company
that can take people's space just
because you found a price and you can
actually pay the price yes doesn't mean
they'll let you go
really still have to pass medical
qualification remember the thing with
the eyes yes okay so
so i uh
uh
uh fortunately the russians didn't care
as much about my eyes
and the fact that i had laser corrective
eye surgery in the meantime actually
became a fascination for nasa really so
because they had actually wanted to
approve that for astronauts but they had
never had a test case wow
i became the test case oh my gosh that's
crazy so it actually became a benefit
yeah they're like uh go up and see see
how that goes but if you're gonna go
blind but then during the medical tests
they discovered that i was missing a
vein
in my liver
so you i read this you then you might if
there was a depressurization you might
bleed out right that's crazy means you
can't go which means oh my god so after
pain you're just like let me bleed out
i'll die in space after after paying
most of the money i'd earn through 30
years making games to russia
i get a phone call saying you can't go
and by the way you're not getting your
money back
did they tell you it was a
non-refundable deposit i knew that oh
that's it ahead of time that's not fair
and so uh
but then you're just going like oh you
know how could this possibly be
happening how could this possibly be
happening but then i got another call
just you know a couple hours later
saying okay we have a plan and the plan
is you know day after tomorrow you have
to go into the hospital and they're
going to remove a big globe of your
liver the day after tomorrow they're
just like yeah by the way thursday
you're going to go in
life threatening surgery geez and so and
when i went to talk to the doctor the
doctor said you just should not go to
space this is
you know i can't advise a healthy person
to uh you know to do this to themselves
it's extremely dangerous you live out
your life happily here on earth but if
you really insist that oh
xxx
and um like one of those matrix jumps
and uh but uh but he said you know if
it's a professional requirement which i
said of course it is you know i'll do it
for you so uh so therefore i have my
that is
and i've got a scar now you know from my
sternum to my belly button over the side
of my body now i would imagine it's a
pretty serious very serious scar or it's
like one of the livers of the major
organs in your body yeah they had to
they had to just pull back all my ab
muscles and everything to get in there
so
god man just like bender they just like
the future i just opened it up and uh
yeah the recovery was lengthy by the way
you guys could read all about this in
richard's book explore create which is
out now it's fantastic by the way i love
like just reading the back the blurbs on
the back elon musk ernest klein who
wrote ready player one stephen hawking
who we'll talk about a second steve
wozniak like unbelievable that's a
pretty yeah even if you don't like the
book yeah just the quotes on the back
what's in the background unbelievable
and uh and you arranged for stephen
hawking's first uh weight lift trip into
weightlessness that's right and he wants
to go to space and i think he'll make it
so uh i would
he'll probably take a suborbital trip
you know we're here soon you know virgin
galactic has already offered him a free
trip that's good
here soon so uh you know i think we
gotta go across with using that triangle
i think if you press trying to jump
yeah maybe i'm wrong i think it didn't
work very well oh you just yeah you just
run across just made it though yeah the
veteran over here knows what he's doing
um that's great so then you so then you
go through some kind of training yeah so
i lived in russia for the better part of
two years and how was that how was
living in russia
yeah well i mean that's about the only
thing i can still say in russia is the
russian language is very difficult
and uh
but uh
you know but all the manuals for the
operations the vehicle are in russian
all the commands are mission controlled
russian
all the instruments in the vehicle are
in russian
so like in gravity it's under a bullet
in fact actually the
the sandra bullock's back of gravity was
incredibly accurate really for those
parts that parts of it that's
unbelievable yeah in fact i was i was
shocked at what a good job they'd done
with uh those details well there you go
nice job sandy good job
and who directed that
who directed that beth you know
i'm trying to think uh gravity alfonso
chrome i think so um that's unbelievable
so then you so i love the fact like
the stakes are pretty high like i need
to learn russian so then i know what
buttons are going to do right now
you know what up on this vehicle called
the soyuz and there is no passenger seat
on these space vehicles the shuttle
actually has a mid deck where the
scientists sit and there's literally
nothing to do oh wow while you're going
up and down i didn't know that but on
the soyuz there's only three people in
it and all three have critical jobs they
better do or you don't survive the trip
it's not like a minivan where you can
just exactly so for example i'm the
first person to get in
but the vehicle the capsule is is turned
off and cold at the time that i enter i
actually literally turn it on holy you
know manage all the power as it
distributes through all of the uh oh
oops
that was me yeah yeah that wasn't it
and um so you you're you're firing up
this rocket
yeah and uh and i i manage all the life
support for my crewmates and myself
uh all the oxygen flow uh all are you
nervous at all i'm nervous hearing this
story no you know you've done it so many
times i see so it's kind of like it's
muscle memory but
your trainers are still on the radio
with you and i don't know i can screw
anything up there's i could literally
screw anything up i'm not sure
that's crazy
the uh the james bond movies were the
only reason i wanted to learn russian
i feel like richard could you easily
could be an international spy at this
point i am yeah you could you could uh
travel the world offering your services
to the highest bidder you know how to
fly uh a
rocket rocket a literally a rocket
you've uh you know how to uh program
computers yep exactly you know how to
you can do it all it's unbelievable yeah
it's funny you know one of my uh
favorite uh little tag lines that has
once been said about me is maxi magazine
called me one of the six most
interesting men in the world you can
actually meet that's true yes
that's actually true with people like uh
the taliban
and a few others
i would say a good company i would and i
would say that is 100 correct i mean
so then all right so i have a question
how what is space smell like what does
it smell like you know it's interesting
because you know technically the vacuum
of space by definition couldn't actually
have a smell right and uh but of course
you're you're locked up in this tin can
yeah that has been recycling its air for
decades sure and uh uh and so it's
reasonable to assume that it does can
get pretty smelly right
it actually doesn't have much of smell
even even that even the space station
uh which does have sections of it that
are frankly kind of moldy
because
no there's no there's no sinks or
bathrooms or toilets or sure right
there's a thing you would consider a
toilet but i mean there's no running
water
uh really anywhere and so when you brush
your teeth or use a baby wipe to clean
yourself with
spittle and
little droplets of water kind of get
scattered all over the walls that's just
like my apartment just like that exactly
there you go exactly i see so the yeah
the little droplets just kind of end up
in the crevices exactly right and so
where wow the area of the space station
that they use for
personal hygiene they they kind of move
it around so that you don't keep the
same area constantly damp and you can
kind of see the places that have been
recently used because they're a little
greener and a little moldier than the
older ones which are kind of dry and
brown that is fascinating wow i think
that's something i would never would
have thought that's i believe nor would
i yeah i mean that's great good alert
were you a and and
how did it feel there was it
claustrophobic like what is is there
anything like that on earth that you've
experienced well so in a feeling well
the space station itself is huge you
know it's bigger than a football field
so i mean once you're up there it's like
you know dozens of buses parked in head
to tail with you know hatches between
them yeah and so there's lots and lots
there's only six of you up there and
there's at least 12 of these modules so
you can you can get lost and be away
from anyone else for the whole day
once you're on the space station oh my
gosh but on the other hand the soyuz
excuse me is is extremely compact sure
and so if you were
at all claustrophobic you wouldn't like
it wow in fact here as a little
demonstration yeah yeah if you and i
were in the soyuz we would be sitting
with your your heels literally touching
your butt we would be literally shoulder
to shoulder your knees be strapped in
and by the way if i was in the commander
seat there'd be a third person here and
i could touch both outer windows the
control panel is touching our knees the
hatch is right here above us and you
might think that we can have a
conversation here yeah except all the
safety gears packed between us you
actually have a heart oh my god god and
so in theory maybe you could try to put
another small person like
that that could sit here but that's
about it that's it you're that is you're
unbelievable oh my god and so it really
is like a tin can with a giant rocket
strap to it i mean you're just well like
95 of the mass
is
you know kerosene and liquid oxygen
and
uh in fact even the one thing you're not
prepared for is you're getting ready to
kind of board this thing for the first
time yeah so you've been through the
simulators you know over and over and
over again so you're confident in the
operations sure but the first time you
know your first time in space is sort of
the first time ever you walk up to a
fully fueled rocket
and when it's full of liquid oxygen
which is you know very cold correct
you know there's not only frost on the
outside of this thing but any air coming
near it is condensing into fog which is
streaming down the sides of it yeah and
it's like popping and cracking and
groaning as it kind of expands and
contracts and yeah and and you just walk
up to it it's like this is it's alive
and so and
it's the biggest bomb you can possibly
imagine i mean if something goes wrong
when you're standing here you know it's
going to take out you know a quarter
mile in every direction
so yeah so man it's impressive that is
just unbelievable and and how was your
time that's really interesting that i i
guess you know i didn't know that the
the international space station was the
size of a football field but i just
didn't think there was that much free
space in there to move around that's
extremely cool
and um yeah
i mean god and so how was so you're up
there for a while you're up there for i
believe eight days 12 days 12 days 12
days uh so that's yeah that's a lot of
time to you know get a chance to you
know float around like superman all day
and all night which is great fun and i
believe that you you did some experience
while you're up there for school
children is that i did it well i did a
ton of experiments i did
commercial experiments to try to make
money to offset the terrible cost of
going yeah and to pay for future flights
of course i did a lot of volunteer
science mostly medical research like my
eyes that's cool and what what is it
like uh what what's that a typical
experiment what is one thing that you
kind of did up there okay so it's uh my
favorite is uh slightly complicated but
i think people will get it uh it was
something called protein crystal growth
if you're if you're a drug maker and you
want to make drugs for people to take to
fight a disease
you the drug the pill you swallow and
hopefully goes in your bloodstream uh
you want it to be a chemical that will
bond strongly with the disease molecule
sure you want it to be able to take down
the disease right so they need to kind
of match up
physically to each other and so one of
the best ways to start that process is
to know the exact shape of the molecule
that's causing the disease okay that
makes sense to me and to get the shape
of the molecule one of the ways you do
that is you make a crystal of it so they
all line up
x-ray diffraction
but if you grow crystals on earth in
gravity
the phase change from liquid to solid
uh creates uh impurities in the crystal
sure but if you grow them in space
there's no
convection currents
and so there's no no forces acting no
forces acting out it could be bigger and
more pure wow and so it should be able
to cut time and money off of the
development of medication that is
fantastic so that's one of the things i
was doing in space or if you're walter
white you can really make some great
mess right exactly so make some really
pure blue sky metal probably could yeah
exactly
um that is just unbelievable and also
like very interesting like because of
course like you are
one of however you know an extremely
small number of people ever to go into
space and so you want to maximize your
time up there right so i was
specifically the 483rd person to leave
here
wow that's crazy oh my goodness yeah my
dad was like number 35. oh my god
that's so cool and your dad was there
when you when you shot up and did he was
there the rocket when i loaded it he ran
my mission control team on the ground
wow the rescue helicopter is picking me
up at the end of it he must have been
and you by the way i believe are the
first uh offspring of any astronaut to
also go into space yes although i flew
also with the first russian so we did it
at the same time that's great so he must
have been i mean unbelief like that's
gotta be so cool yeah to have your dad
there is just exactly right and what's
funny also though is is my dad is
literally spock
and i mean literally in a sense of you
know he is unemotional
simple logical unflappable guy
and so you know he wouldn't become even
emotional about me flying or not i mean
he's literally completely disappointed
but but i could tell by the time i
finished the flight right that i got the
yeah you did you did well son wow look
he didn't say it right sir you could
just tell you could sense it oh my
goodness kind of thing i think we
actually have a photo of you in the
space station can we cut to that real
quick this is such a great photo and i
love i love that somebody had somebody
had to be upside down so in all every
and every weightlessness you know
because which way is down right exactly
that's true if you turn the photo over
it's just yeah that's absolutely true
that's so good and then you also this is
a patch from your mission which is
extremely cool
so it has that's great look at my name
garriott on one side uh american mike
fink on the other our commander yuri
loncich off on the top 100th man soyuz
launch ever on the bottom it says soyuz
tma13 oh my gosh and there are 17 stars
for the 17 people who have died either
going to or wow
oh my gosh and then there's you three
right there because it's customary to
take your commander's call sign oh and
his air force call center was titan so
we are titan one titan two and types of
three that's great holding up the euro
what a great call sign yeah you know
it's not like one of his costumes like
goober when you got it you got a tip
a bunch of goobers who would have dealt
with it
but again your your space goobers which
is better than any other kind i don't
even know what a gooper is like isn't
that that chocolate covered peanut yeah
yeah yeah it's a peanut or something
unbelievable now okay well let's come
back to the earth for a second so you
went down
in the water under to the titanic yeah
well and what's interesting is this is
all part of the same journey of space
really yes because the same group of us
that formed the x prize and zero g and
space adventures yes we
also uh some of this predates me the
founding these like mike mcdowell one of
our co-founders he started pork
expeditions the first company to take
people to the north pole and icebreakers
we started something called deep ocean
expeditions the the charters these mere
submersibles that james cameron
chartered those submarines from deep
ocean expeditions
gosh which is why we could go take those
same submarines and go down the titanic
that's so cool so
uh and then we took those same subs down
to uh
find some treasure racks and go to see
hydrothermal vents these very special
uh
wait wait wait let's back up so
you're going you went actually treasure
hunting in a submarine absolutely on and
how does that work like what do you mean
you just went what are you on google
maps how do you know like what's ah well
how does that specifically so the first
trip we made how we found it is one of
our partners
helped bring up the liberty bell 7 space
capsule that nasa had lost in the
atlantic wow and when they were doing
the side scan sonar for that
they saw what is to any lay person
obviously a ship a wooden ship lying on
the bottom of the ocean that no one had
known what was it was uncharted and
there was no record of itself
so we said well let's just take the subs
and go check it out and so i love that
hey that's what's happening pack a
sandwich
that's exactly what we did
and uh and so uh
with that uh in in hand so to speak we
went down there and sure enough there
was a
ship that was full of coconuts and rum
bottles
so we called it the pina colada
name
but it also had in the captain's
quarters it had uh uh some treasure
chests full of gold and silver coins
literally literally what we're doing
right now in golf you've done in real
exactly at the bottom of the ocean
unbelievable
unbelievable that is crazy and so and
and what is it like being because those
subs i tell the james cameron thing it's
like it's very very tight it is but it's
almost the same as a soyuz but that's i
mean it's about the same size wow three
people in it just like the soyuz sure
and uh the life support systems is a co2
scrubber and bleeding in oxygen like on
the soyuz very similar and so yeah they
except maybe in english this time maybe
not in russian uh no you're still in
russia okay still interesting
so yeah
that's so funny and was it was there
anything i mean like what's something
that would surprise people about being
that deep in a submarine
well so despite the the submarine being
made at a very thick steel yes uh the
pressure down at the depth of the
titanic is 70 000 pounds per square inch
oh my god and that is enough pressure to
compress
this metal sphere by an amount you can
measure with the yardstick oh my god god
you know you are you are it is really
really really really deep
and uh talk about like groaning i mean
that must have been a whole other well
and also you know i do a lot of
exploration travel activities and so you
know i pay a great deal of attention to
safety and i learn all the systems even
if i'm not going to be the sub driver i
want to know how it all works absolutely
all the safety systems work knowledge is
power knowledge is power
and
so before we went down to the titanic
you know i went through all the safety
systems so i know i'm you know we have a
few days of oxygen a few days of co2
scrubbing plenty of food and water and
how long are you down in this you're
down about 12 hours oh wow so crazy
that's a long time
it takes a couple hours just to get spot
a couple hours to get back up and it's
really
that is nuts and uh but what's
interesting is you know you know
probably one of the biggest dangers you
might think of down there is getting
stuck you know like maybe you get it
tangled up in some nets or something
somebody's dropped right someone you
cannot have someone else come and help
you it seems right well there's another
submarine in theory but there's not
necessarily much they could do even with
another submarine but it's somewhat nice
to think that the other submarine could
help oh my gosh but uh
but what's interesting is you know if
you get entangled
there's light booms you can eject
there's uh remote manipulators that you
can eject light booms when you mean uh
lights oh i see but booms big booms with
lighting
so that uh you can light up something
you're taking filming
but you can eject those booms
if you get them tangled up
right so make sure you don't get stuck
on the bottom
attached right and you can eject uh
your side thrusters and you can eject
the main prop in the back you've got two
giant battery trays underneath that you
can drop uh and if you were to do all
that the little capsule that's left
would be incredibly positively buoyant
and a little capsule spear-like device
so it's gonna be very slippery sure so
you think it's gonna be pretty easy to
get to the top you know almost anything
you can imagine you'll be able to get it
and you know or you'll either pull it
with you maybe right
you'll be incredibly powerful yes
uh and even if you can't get up then
there's a door that pops open and you
can there's a really long rope with a
buoy that goes to the surface so that
the other sub could follow it back down
and maybe find you wow and the radios
that are on board are called acoustic
phones so they actually make a
piezoelectric noise in the water so
they're actually making waves and uh and
that's a line of sight so you need to be
you need to speak you can't have a
mountain between you and the other side
or the people on the surface to hear it
but you know the ocean is pretty clear
and so that's uh you know
shouldn't be a problem yes unless you do
what we did
i love this this is going to be great so
you know we go down to the titanic we
sit and have lunch on the deck of the
titanic we go down in the main staircase
and look at all the views you saw in the
movie titanic we saw by eye at the bow
and the place had broken open and the
last spot we go to is the stern to go
look at the plot the props
so
you know to get down there when the
titanic hit the ground it kind of dug up
a trench a little bit and so there's
sort of a dirt berm behind it okay and
so as you approach it you go over the
berm you come down on the side of the
berm and you come over and you look at
the props you're going like look there's
the props yeah sure and
then when it was time to go
you lift up off the ground and
bang we hit the bottom of the titanic
and the titanic is rusting into nothing
sure and so suddenly all this debris
goes
on top
it's a titanic avalanche literally
that's crazy now remember all those
safety measures i described
we've just defeated all of them
all of them
i don't care how buoyant you are if
you're if the titanic is sitting on top
of you you're not getting up
there's no buoy you can launch that
anybody can see and the radios don't
work because you're out of line of sight
to anyone oh my you're covered in
rusting titanic metal right
that's great were you freaking out
well what's interesting is
you realize that this at that moment you
go like wow literally every safety
measure that you had this confidence in
like the titanic itself
you know has just been defeated you
realize that if if the worst has
happened there's really no way to get
out of it there's literally even if they
could they won't find you but even if
they did yeah they they couldn't know
what are they going to do
and so all you can do and you now you
have visibility is truly zero this is
this is when we find out you died 30
years ago
yeah exactly what's happening
i'm just talking to myself
but uh but we uh
uh
you just sit there you actually wait we
sat there for probably an hour maybe two
to wait for the
silt and the water to clear so loud and
then you know you have these little tiny
little portholes you're looking at going
like well you know
you can't see anything because you're
just looking down into the mud
and then all you do is you go like well
let's try to lift off let's you know
pump a little ballast out and try to
become you know try to see if we lift up
and sure enough we lift up we lift a
little off the bottom and then
we
turn around in place kind of sketching
along the bottom a little bit uh and
then we drive forward to that berm and
then kind of climb up the mud you know
to get out but we but we had actually
broken that first bang broke this
titanium bumper set that was around the
subs
because you were back when the props
which is probably the most reinforced
part of yeah yeah and we hit it hard you
know it's a 25 ton submarine so
any momentum it has is gonna hit hard
and so yeah we hit it hard and i kept
actually the bracket that the titanium
bumpers are attached the sub width
because they it wasn't attaching
anything anymore so i right i kept it as
a memento of my so you just picked it up
with the sub no no no we actually uh it
was still the cleat was still attached
to the sub oh wow oh that's when we on
the surface
and so we did make it out but but that
was a one of these examples of you know
you just never know when
you know it's it's the things you don't
think about yeah we're gonna get you yes
absolutely
you probably deal with i mean and the
thing too that that's so fascinating
about that is
so for an hour you kind of sat there you
didn't know
what your fate was going to be right
exactly right that is un that's that's
crazy i mean you know you just
what was flashing through your head i
mean you're very accomplished but you've
got it you've got it yeah well all of us
you know you know
all three of us were on board we're like
oh you know
the irony was not lost on us at all
right that you know that wow we have
just defeated
all of the safety measures and you know
we chuckled about it you're like you
still try the radios and of course
nobody nobody can hear you and so uh you
know you go like oh that's not
unexpected
but
kind of unfortunate right
what how does it work with so you know
obviously you're you leave you're
ejected from a you launch from a ship on
the surface to go down and so is there
do you say oh we're gonna be down for x
amount of time if we don't come back
like you know like is there no yeah so
you're when you're out of radio contact
for more than 15 minutes they got it
they assume
they want to reach you they assume
something and so they knew for example
that we were heading down to the stern
so they would have known generally
speaking i see where we were because of
where we checked in last and what we
told them our intentions were yeah um so
you know you don't you don't just go
rove around you're like all right see
see you guys so you guys are from
seriously 12 hours
so you're trying
and uh but um
if you guys are just joining us we're
with we're with with uh richard garriott
he uh he created the ultimate series he
has been to space he's been to the
bottom of the ocean uh he has written an
amazing book about all these things
called explore create uh it's fantastic
it's out now uh and of course uh and
you've got a game coming it's playing
games you still make games yeah games
that's right so let's let's talk about
the new game that's coming out this
summer the new game is called shroud of
the avatar it's uh
basically the spiritual successor to the
ultima series awesome uh which i haven't
really worked in medieval fantasy and
kind of specifically these virtue based
games that i did with ultima's yeah uh
you know for a decade so yeah getting
back to my roots that's great and that's
gotta be fun i mean it's gotta be like
slipping on an old pair of shoes to a
certain destination exactly and you know
and i sort of purposely didn't do it for
the last decade because you know the
first 20 years of my career was sort of
you know it's treading the in many ways
the same turf
uh but now it's not only have i been
away for it long enough and but
technology has advanced a lot yes
absolutely and a whole new wave of
gamers would come in who didn't really
experience the kind of games that i like
to create absolutely and so uh now
seemed like the right time to go back
and do it and what do you what are you
excited about with with your new uh and
it's going to be you said if this is
only the first installment that's
correct
you know so so with the ultima series
not only was it some of the first ever
role-playing games and first games that
had truly deep stories about virtue as
opposed to just level branding for
monsters yeah yes right which is what
we're doing yeah yeah
on the grind and uh in my games you know
you you had to prove yourself worthy not
just in might but in
moral compass absolutely yeah and virtue
in virtue in order to succeed yes uh and
so this also fulfills that plus it is
both an online and offline game since uh
i helped kind of develop the both of
those standards in the
uh master of all domains
uh and but what's interesting about this
game too is that well it's not only both
online and offline
it lets the game itself sort of
throttles up and down between single
player and multiplayer as it needs to or
wants to wow that's pretty cool you can
do detailed storytelling
uh
you know in a multiplayer environment
and unlike a lot of mmos which people
are broken up into different copies of
the world
he's a jerk for sure i am back
watch out for him
again he's good he's got these two oh no
oh i got now but uh but the new game uh
it puts everybody in the same play world
versus splitting them up that's cool uh
which i think is also an advantage so
there's
yeah i mean one of the things i have to
say is one of the trends and games i i
don't like right now is there is a you
know like i have the most fun with this
couch co-op i love this yeah yeah
and but i also like playing you know
sometimes i like multiplayer sometimes i
like uh single player you know and it's
interesting because when titanfall came
out right from like giant um there was
no single player and that kind of taught
me oh wait i play single player to then
learn how to play multiple like oh here
are the weapons i like this is the
strategy i like
um so that's great i love the fact yeah
and in fact the way i the reason we
started this is because you know i
travel all the time yes and if you make
a game that can't and not just on this
planet by the way yeah
interplanetary yes exactly and uh but i
want to be able to play when i'm on an
airplane yeah or just off grid
absolutely and uh and so that was sort
of one of the founding principles of
starting this game is to have it play
both online and offline absolutely and
for people you know even like our armed
forces and stuff you know they don't
have a lot of they play a lot of video
games and um they don't get a chance to
a lot of times have good you know like
broadband connections out there and
cutter or whatever
um it was funny we do this uh series on
the show called clueless gamer recording
i play video games
and i don't think we have had more fans
than when we went with michelle obama to
this forward air base in qatar everyone
there just after like saying lines you
know all the service men and women were
saying like lines from the different
games uh the sketches we've done i mean
it was really cool so that's awesome
that's fantastic i agree i completely
agree that's very very exciting yeah
well what other adventures do you have
in store what what other moans are there
so there's so many more to do maybe
everest maybe mountain stick well you
know what's interesting is uh you might
think that i do these things that seem
dangerous but i'm actually very
practical the the you know one out of
every four for every person who has for
every four people that have summoned
everest one person has died attempting
to summon everest yeah yeah and so
that's pretty dangerous yes very no i
don't i don't care i slice it those are
bad odds bad odds and so everest is not
on my must-do list no but you know there
are things left like i have not been to
the north pole yet but i'm trying to wow
and so i'm trying to uh you know
find a way to take my kids to the north
pole wow that would be great and my kids
are only two and four at the moment oh
my goodness and by the way your kids are
the coolest names ever by the way yeah
well we had fun with their names yeah i
think king guys
is our daughter's first name yeah her
middle name is shuilong which is a water
dragon in chinese because before we knew
it was a girl we we knew it was gonna be
born in the chinese
water dragon so we named the water
dragon unbelievable and your full name
by the way because you i think you and
your uh you and your wife
yeah i added well i'm a big believer
that women changing their last name to
meet a man's last name is part of the
patriarchal past oh yes it actually
works against women's equality i you
know i love that yes and so uh
you know i i uh resist that and so uh
uh anyway um
we i endeavored not to have that happen
very cool very cool uh yeah so your last
name is actually gary day caillou
caillou yes which is like man that is
the coolest my wife's
i love that that is so cool i've got
blair i'm stuck with something that
sounds like when you dry eve
it's the worst oh man you sort of
inherit that person yeah
you can't change it that's true that's
true i just gotta marry someone with a
really cool last name exactly and then
it'll be exactly amazing
make up a new one exactly well so
everest is not on your list what do you
what are you seeing out in the north
pole so the thing we're doing nowadays
is visiting disappearing indigenous
populations of the earth before they
disappear wow and so we actually took
the kids when when our son was only six
months old and our daughter was two and
a half
we went to uh
but it didn't work very well
uh we went into the mountainous regions
between
thailand cambodia and laos wow with kids
literally on our backs uh into the
jungles wow that is so cool that's
unbelievable there's tons of thought to
do and how was that i mean how were the
bugs how was that how's that experience
was it it wasn't nearly as bad as you
think because we even we didn't bring a
domestic
nanny or person with us at all but we
what we did is we hired locals oh that's
so smart so we uh which worked out great
yeah and so sort of a added to the
cultural experience that's very fun
anyway it's interesting like when i went
to belize and stayed in the jungle a
little bit there and there were no bugs
because the bats ate them all yeah which
is kind of exciting yeah you kind of
when you get out i think into the world
it's like kind of nature takes care of
itself in a certain way yeah exactly
right um in certain areas in certain
areas yes that's true in other areas
it's incredibly incredibly dangerous
wow that is absolutely unbelievable and
so and we talked a little bit before you
uh you kind of uh arranged for stephen
hawking to uh how did that come about
yeah and so what was interesting is that
was peter dumanis's idea
and um
and you know we
he just said look you know here's
stephen hawking he's a person who you
know talks about space wants to go to
space
it's going to be a while before we have
any vehicles that could take him to
space yeah uh why don't we take one of
zero g flight and by the way
zero g flight is not a cheap thing to
run to operate the airplane sure yeah so
you know to take stephen hawking on a
flight would really require us to do
some test flights and other things ahead
of time so there's gonna be hundreds of
thousands of dollars of cost right and
so what we did is we called up all the
board members including myself and
others and we said why don't we all
share the cost so let's let's go with
stephen he's the smartest player to go
and then we get the cool fun of going
with stephen hawking
yeah and we we shared that idea with him
and he was like heck yeah he's like yeah
i'm good and we've actually been great
friends ever since i was just in uh
london at his 75th birthday last month
oh my gosh that's hilarious and i walked
from literally the house i was born in
to his house whoa on the day of his 75th
birthday that is and that's you know
again why is that you know he did the
quote for me in the back yes absolutely
yeah all has grown out of us you know
doing this zero g flight stuff together
that's so cool and how is he as a person
he seems like a pretty cool guy he's
actually he's a shockingly cool guy yeah
and he is a shockingly glib guy
and what's interesting about that though
is you know if you're familiar with how
he talks yes it's very slow and it's
very asynchronous yes he can't like
respond in real time right and so what
you do is you talk to steve
and then when he gets a break of about
30 minutes he will compose a reply wow
there's sort of a lag between what you
say and how he responds interesting but
when he does respond it is always very
articulate very witty i believe
and um uh
and you know i i just uh you know find
it just in incredible fun to have a
conversation with him just because sure
so glib in fact you know that's so in a
lot of ways it's kind of like it's kind
of like talking on a live chat where
it's like there's a delay you ask a
question then later he kind of responds
that's right and the delay is like 30
minutes right right exactly
that's great man i love the fact that he
um
he held that uh
like you know the party for time
travelers did you hear about that of
course um which is just like the cool
and so you know he's got to have a great
sense of humor absolutely when somebody
like does that um which is extremely
cool oh let's see what am i carrying
here what is this thing you know and
what i also find some humor in when you
like i've heard him give presentations
and things a number of times and yeah uh
you know what what's funny is uh
you know of course his his his knowledge
of the universe is great right but uh
but uh uh something that is a little
tricky is for him to
know what people don't know and so he'll
start with something that everybody
knows you're going like i'm enjoying
this yes and then he'll cross over this
like oh my god he's like
what is he talking about
way over my head i think i'll like go
two or three more levels deep wow okay
i'm not worthy i'm still you know uh i'm
always behind unbelievable i'm learning
like a brick says uh uh he heard that
stephen hawking refused to upgrade his
voice to a less robotic one because he
considered the old one his own voice
that's so cool that's true really cool
and by the way tons of people you know
there's new technology coming out these
days that also could help him speak more
fluidly which would be a huge advantage
yes but the uh but the problem is that
you know
none of that is quite mature enough yet
and tons of people come to him claiming
they have it worked out and would love
to have him as a first user i'm sure but
in fact most of them don't really have
it all quite worked out and it sort of
wastes his time
right which is very valuable
yeah exactly so uh so yeah but he's he
does quite well with what he's got
that's extremely cool we were on tour um
with conan uh a bunch of years ago and
one of our co-workers spotted him by the
way best celebrity sighting ever uh
coming out of this hotel in new york and
i guess people don't realize but the
chair is like a it's not like just a
normal chair it's like a huge oh yeah
it's like a giant thing and like he was
flanked by supermodels and i was like
well that is just that makes me so happy
that like you know stephen hawking is
the man he shouldn't be playing by
supermodels at all times
i mean that is just unbelievably clear
and and you know and
and what's interesting is stephen is
always you know not only surrounded by
supermodels in case you were describing
but also just
smart people and interesting people and
you know league of legends yeah there's
there's no one that doesn't enjoy you
know
being seen of course
i mean
so and he's very open
i mean
he's still very humble and personally
even though he's this completely yeah
right you know the first few times i
would go to see him like i've seen him
at cambridge university and you know
you're sort of intimidated to go hey i'm
gonna go walk up to his office and knock
on the door and see if i can get in and
um uh but uh
but you know they're his his whole staff
is also very good about
um you know uh understanding that people
want to talk to him and he wants to talk
to other people too because of course
you know and uh so uh yeah he's quite
social that is unbelievable and and you
know you yourself as well extremely
intimidating what would you say to
people who want to do the things you've
done and and you know get into some of
the fields and some of the things you've
accomplished like
well what's interesting is um
you know for computer games i think i
was
uh just at the right age at the right
time you know i've worked hard
and i think i'm pretty creative and
smart but i also know for a fact that i
was well placed to take advantage of it
yes luck luck as well
but i'm but i'm a believer of you know
luck is the intersection between
opportunity and preparation
and
and opportunities will happen all the
time yes i think almost every day every
person
has a moment or two where they could
advance their either current career or
make headways towards something new if
they were paying attention right and
chose to take that risk and chose to put
in that effort then and then some
fraction of those times it'll work yeah
to make an incremental
improvement yeah and so like getting
myself to space was something i knew it
was going to be hard
i had no illusions
be a
difficult journey yes but i thought you
know there's no real reason it shouldn't
work there's no foundational it's not
impossible if i said if i said i want to
build a light speed you know faster than
light vehicle i'm going well you know i
don't i cannot conceivable way to do
that yes but at least for this for space
i'm going i can conceive of it right
people have done it people have done it
the technology exists yes you know it
has a cost you know we can measure it
you know uh yeah and in particular with
going to russians the reason why we knew
that would work is we saw them doing
things like trading tanks for a guy
going to space for some third world
country
well that means the flight is worth five
tanks
and calculate five tanks that's 20
million dollars yeah it's got to be 20
million dollars and you can watch if you
transact google currency converter yes
tank system rubles
and so that's why we said you know we
know this will work yes and uh and so
their first response to some yahoos call
them is like forget it right but then
you go okay why and you go like well to
even their answer to that was because to
even calculate a price and see how we
would train you
and see if nasa would accept us or how
we'd fly these civilians that would that
would cost us money to determine that
answer yes and we said well that's a
qualified yes yes so and it's a
quantitative cost yes to do that work
absolutely and their answer to that was
300 grand and i was like i'm in
[Laughter]
here's 300 grand i had two tanks
after they spent my 300 grand they came
back and said 20 million dollars that's
exactly what we thought right and uh
sadly for me that was also in the year
2000 with the internet stock market
crash dot com bubble yes and so that
first seat which was my seat
went i couldn't pay for it right and uh
we instead had to give it to a guy named
dennis tito who became the first private
citizen to go yes who like me had also
been pursuing this his whole life right
right and so you know more power to him
right but
he's still amazing but i still made it i
had to circle back and
build more companies
yes it was not wasted work at all in any
way um but that's so cool and so i guess
kind of like being self-aware and not
taking notes don't take no for an answer
yeah and and if it fails if you fail at
something
and you know why it failed and you can
go wow i've learned through this and
even though today i may not be prepared
or i don't have the money or i don't
have the team or whatever the reasons
are you can't proceed
if you believe you can strategize about
how you could at least go a little
farther next time
then start working towards it again yes
if that's something you really want to
do like go to space yes and so uh so you
know i'm a very patient person like i'm
working on my one of my latest little
side projects is personal rapid transit
a an automated people mover yes to you
know move people around in cities off
the roadway which uh you know in
addition to self-driving cars i think is
going to be frankly needed absolutely
and uh but it's but it requires public
property private property city state
local governments all to agree rights uh
and a lot of money yeah and so that's
true and so i know it's going to be a
long-term project but i've already been
working on it a decade and maybe it'll
take 20 more years yeah whatever it
takes i'm going to help make sure it
gets through i'm telling you we were in
mexico city last week and that is a city
that absolutely needs something
wow because
yeah mexico city i love you but your
traffic is is worse than la and i mean
that in all the ways possible it's great
that is pretty bad by the way every time
i come out here that's the one thing i
can say
getting around the city i'd rather be in
a tiny tiny uh space campsite yeah
that's exactly um well richard gary
thank you so much absolutely the book is
explore create it's absolutely fantastic
go pick it up now and of course shroud
of the avatar forsaken virtues comes out
this summer uh the first installment and
many more to come so check that out and
thank you guys for joining us for stream
coco we will see you guys next week see
you later bye
you